I started with the smiley face I added
the meta tag with a character set of
utf-8 to the head of the page this is so
that unicode characters get recognized
then all I had to do is go to the
Unicode site and copy and paste the
smiley face here to add the social media
icons I added a link to social in the
head using the wheel of icon fonts
website at the bottom of the page i
added a footer tag with a div inside
with an ID of social inside there are 48
eggs each of which has a different class
notice how all the classes start with
social and then a dash and then the
social icon that I wanted so I've got
Twitter Facebook Google+ and dig I
thought the logos look just a little
bland on their own so I wound up using
some CSS to give them some shadows and
in the end I thought the flourish was
just a little silly so I added a slight
border using border bottom to the end of
the article I think this is a little bit
classier and it avoids some extra bytes
for the flourish you could have also
used some kind of SVG here but I decided
to go with a little bit more subtle
approach oh and here's my SVG logo it's
pretty simple so I just simply inlined
it here inside the header alright this
blog is looking much more reasonable
we've dropped some unnecessary bytes and
added some social media icons at the end
of the next lesson you'll have one more
opportunity to really make this blog's
images shine